um i i appreciate everyone's who's here
although
um those who are um not in the summer
internship or or new
to the program do not feel obligated to
stay
um this is really um in the summer we
have these sessions mainly for our
summer interns but we invite everyone
um and they get a chance to hear um
about
uh the work that people do and so forth
um
so that's um that that's what i am um
uh doing today and um but we we invite
everyone so
um if those of you who want to uh listen
in uh
you're more than welcome to do so and um
and and then um i've also tried to
um to not take up the whole hour talking
so that there will be some time for um
question and answers and again
anyone can feel free to ask questions
although
the focus of this session again is on
the summer interns and those who are
otherwise
new um to the program and the department
and if some of you have been to our
either open house or other kind of
sessions
some of these slides may look familiar
to you
so um i'm going to go ahead
and put myself in presentation mode
and i will warn people ahead of time
that um
i am home alone today with my dog
who i hopefully uh gave something to do
to keep him
busy the next hour but uh um may need to
to switch switch to that activity if
something happens
so anyways um i am um
bill hirsch uh you all probably know me
or know
of me i see some of you are current
students in the program and
um uh it's great to see you all
and and my purpose here um you know is
to give an overview of the field the
department and
educational programs so
um i i was gonna do
introductions but um that may actually
be challenging um so
um maybe we'll skip that although when
people do speak up
uh please introduce yourselves and of
what
uh program your fund from um feel free
to
um post things in the chat which i will
get to when i
uh finish my presentation um you're
welcome to keep your video
on um we encourage people to turn their
audio
off if you're not talking just so
there's no uh
background noise um so mainly i'm going
to focus on
the second the overview of the
informatics field the department our
educational programs
and then um we'll open it up for any
questions and answers about
anything um so um
so again some of you have seen this
slide
but i know that for the summer interns
and maybe others who are new to the
field
what is this field called informatics i
i like this venn diagram that
shows it's the confluence of people
information and technology
applied in something related to health
or health care or public health
i have a website that i was able to
snag one of the new dot health top-level
domain
so informatics.health type it into your
browser
you'll get me and um
and one point i always like to make is
um you know it's it's more about data
and information than it is about
technology obviously you can't do much
with data and information
without using technology but really the
focus is on the data and information
and what we do with it to improve
people's health
and health care delivery
there are many um sub areas of
the overarching field which we sometimes
which we usually call biomedical
informatics or even
the name i actually prefer biomedical
and health informatics
and then the different areas
correspond to whether we're focused on
the
cell on cellular processes and that's
bioinformatics whether we're focused on
people
which we most commonly call clinical
informatics
and um or whether we're focused on
populations in public health informatics
and then within clinical or medical
informatics there's
medical informatics there's informatics
devoted to different clinical fields
pathology
radiology etc and also consumer health
informatics
and there are actually other probably
the word informatics is used most
in biomedicine but there's a field of
legal informatics chemo informatics
there's a field called museum
informatics that focuses on informatics
issues for museums
you know and as you know museums spend a
lot of time cataloging artifacts and so
forth
and um then there's these kind of
overarching areas
imaging informatics research informatics
um that hang on let me stop for one
second here i'm going to let my dog out
there you go um okay that should
hopefully take care of this for a while
um and uh research informatics which um
uh there is applied to different um
uh areas of research um sometimes called
um like clinical research informatics
which which is focused around all of the
clinical and translational research
um so there's a lot happening um
in in the world that informatics is
connected to there are many important
roles that it plays
uh whether it's um electronic health
records so
tracking what we do in healthcare maybe
even using that data
to predict things that patients might
need how we can deliver their care
better
improve the quality and safety the whole
area of data science that is
versioning machine learning artificial
intelligence
really in its early days in terms of the
actual contributions
most physicians actually have very
little to do these days with
clinical with machine learning
in their day-to-day work that will
obviously change in the future
precision medicine a term you may have
heard of you know bringing
more precise diagnosis and treatment to
patients
um especially all of the omics genomics
proteomics the microbiome etc and then
the whole
kind of patient connected side personal
health records so
personal health record being what
patients how patients interact with
their electronic health record
uh probably many of you um get your care
at places that use
epic so you may use my chart that's
probably the most widely used personal
health record
so someone um if someone can is there's
noise in the background can
mute your line um thank you
um and um and but other things that
patients do wearable devices on things
like that
and um and of course there's the
important role
of informatics and cobit 19. um covid19
has certainly
exposed problems with our health care
system
it certainly exposed how our data and
information systems are not as
good as they could be and it's also
exposed other fault lines in society
systemic racism
other inequities that we have in our
society
but this then provides opportunities for
us and in fact there's
actually a big push by the government to
improve our public health reporting
systems
there's even going to be funding for
public health informatics workforce
development
to help build those information
systems and get us out of the current
pandemic and perhaps
guide us put us in a better position
when the next one happens
and then also reforming health care and
other aspects of our larger society that
benefit the common good
um we knew actually that there were
career
opportunities well before
the pandemic as some of you know this
has been an interest of mine you know
how big is the healthcare i.t workforce
um
we i uh and some others published some
research in 2018 showing that
as the scope of healthcare i.t continues
to grow as
healthcare organizations take on more
informatics related tasks
that there could be anywhere from 19 000
to 153
000 more jobs in the united states um
and and of course back then we weren't
really thinking about things like
telehealth and so forth
um so um and in terms of opportunities
in informatics
in terms of sheer numbers the largest
quantity
of opportunity is in the health care
system but there are
plenty of other important opportunities
and many alumni of our program
work at research institutes in
industry in um government
and so forth um
this is a report that was published in
2018 the future of jobs that looked at
jobs whose that jobs that were
emerging um and jobs that were declining
and you can see if you look down under
the list
of emerging jobs there's a lot of things
related to biomedical informatics
data analysts data science ai machine
learning
i.t big data
and then if you look at the jobs that
were decreasing data entry clerks
although
actually we still need good data to be
entered
um but um other things that that were
decreasing and i don't know how much the
pandemic has impacted this because we
know that there are plenty of industries
now that are
looking to hire people but anyways this
was an interesting report so um
most of you probably know that our
program
is housed in our department the
department of medical informatics and
clinical epidemiology
or demise as our acronym is pronounced
we are an academic department in the
school of medicine at ohsu so
as i'm chair of the department my boss
is the dean
of the school of medicine and um
like many other departments we um
our mission is to provide leadership
discovery and dissemination of knowledge
through research education and service
we happen to apply it in these two
fields other departments supply it and
other fields
i'm only mostly going to focus on
informatics today but we do have another
part of d mice the clinical epidemiology
side of the department
that focuses in areas like
evidence-based medicine
systematic reviews medic meta-analysis
things like that um and and of course
um we we have a large department um
with about 100 employees
the rest of the department leadership is
listed here
and and some of these individuals are um
involved in the informatics education
program others are not
um but uh shannon mcweeney heads the
bioinformatics and actually that should
say computational biomedicine
which we changed to a few years ago
david door is very focused on
research and clinical research
informatics karen eden
does faculty development she also has a
leadership role in the phd
program and cindy morris who's more on
the clinical epi side
um but um she also directs a program
that some of you may have heard of at
portland state called build exeter
that is increasingly interdigitated with
our
program so um if you went
to say u.s news and world report and
just like you can look up the best
medical school the best law school the
best accounting school
there are no rankings for biomedical
informatics which is actually probably a
good thing
but um but that said
you know how do you know whether a
program is a national leader well
you can look at the kinds of
accomplishments that the program
has so for example we are one of 16
programs that
are funded through the national library
medicine
training grant for phd and postdoc
students
which is a distinguished group of
informatics programs around the country
that are
leaders in education and research
when there was funding from the office
of the national coordinator for health
i.t for workforce development we were
one of nine programs funded
there have been international funding
efforts like through the nih fogerty
center
we were funded under that program we
are consistent recipient of research
funding
last year our research funding was
something on the order of 15 million
dollars in research grants
our faculty are appointed to national
and even sometimes international
leadership roles and we have
um publications in high profile journals
and all of the kind of uh
things that academic and research
leaders do
and we also have a large and
distinguished alumni i'll actually
talk about them in a moment but um
we have over 800 alumni dating back to
the late 1990s
and our clinical epidemiology program on
the other side of the department even
though they don't
do um
they don't have they don't do as much
education as we do in informatics but
they're
they're very uh successful and well
known around the world
um for example they've been involved in
some of the
living systematic reviews that have been
done around covid related topics
on drugs um
efficacy of face mass and things like
that
so um our uh what
brings a significant number large number
of people to our department is our
graduate program our educational program
and um it really is i think for us a
crown jewel
many of us on the faculty and staff are
very passionate about our program
and really aiming to achieve that goal
of training future
professionals researchers leaders in the
field
um so we have two different majors in
our program i'll talk about in a moment
um and like most informatics
programs all programs are at the
graduate level so require a bachelor's
degree to enter
i i think over time we may see more
undergraduate
programs just checking on my dog if
you're looking at my screen
um and um and then we have
a diverse student body um in terms of
their backgrounds
and um where they come from careers and
so forth but typically
fall into one of two categories we some
people
come in because they're still
in their primary education which may
include graduate school
these students are more likely to be
full-time um
quote-unquote on campus everyone is
virtual now but
when we do in the future uh go come back
to campus um
we'll have more students around on
campus but we also have this cadre of
what we sometimes think of as
career-changing uh students they are
individuals who are uh more likely to
um be changing their careers
a good number of them are from
healthcare professions so
physicians nurses pharmacists others
although not exclusively we have people
from
many different backgrounds but are
typically wanting to move their career
change their career into informatics and
they tend to be part-time they tend to
be enrolled
in our online program and um
they of course we we all interact as one
happy family since a lot of our
courses even before the pandemic were
online
they interact with each other which we
think adds a lot of richness to the
program so our program
we used to call them tracks our provost
insisted that we change them
to majors so in our overall biomedical
informatics program
you can major in either health and
clinical informatics which we abbreviate
hcin
or bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine
which we abbreviate bcb the original
program
actually back when it was formed was
actually called medical informatics but
we now call it hcin it was really
focused on
on health and health care and to to a
lesser extent public health and clinical
research
um it's it's focused really really on
kind of the core of informatics and and
applied
data analytics the bcb program
started with a very kind of
bioinformatics focus so
focus on the different omics genomics
proteomics the the microbiome
but has really expanded including
clinical
uh data and um and the bcb
program uh gets more focuses more deeply
on
the the data science and and machine
learning and
um some of our hcin students
um opt to pursue the the machine
learning in the bcb
major um the um that
that requires a a very
strong mathematical background that not
everyone may have especially people
who have been trained as healthcare
professionals
um so um the um i mentioned the
department leadership
so the um the program leadership
um is somewhat similar um i i serve as
overall director of the program
um and oversee the hcin major
along with actually karen eden i um
actually nicole weiskopf has now
taken a role um in this position she
should be added to this slide
um and then um shannon and ailesh
boudreau overseeing the bcb
program and and then really critical um
just as important if not more important
than the leadership is the faculty
who teach courses advise students
mentor them on projects and so forth and
and those of you who are summer interns
are
already paired up with a faculty member
and most of the
other students in the program
get paired up as well
so um our program is our informatics
graduate program is one of the oldest
and largest
in the country in the world maybe um
we're not the oldest there have been
some that have been around longer
we were a fairly early adopter of machi
of online learning i was going to say
machine learning there
online learning um and uh we we like to
keep this a map of where our
online students live and as you can see
there may be a little bit clustered in
the
pacific northwest but um all over the
country
and um as i mentioned before
um the the our numbers we so we have
awarded
872 degrees and certificates to
782 people some have more than one
and um you see here the numbers the
hcin program is larger and has been
around longer
it also has the graduate certificate
program that the bcb
program does not um and
we have um 782
alumni we keep in touch with them
i actually see a few of them are on this
conference
and we're very proud of all that they
accomplish in in academia
in operational settings and hospitals
and research institutes and so forth
um and um we we do uh
try to keep in touch with them and um
engage with them
and so as you can see we've awarded a
few hundred master's degrees
31 phds and a large number of
certificates
since the internet knows no boundaries
our program
knows no boundaries although sometimes
we run into political
challenges when individuals from some
countries want to enroll
um i would love to see that all go away
but i'm not going to change that
um but we we have students take our
courses
online from all the countries listed
here singapore thailand argentina those
are probably the three main
groups that we've countries that we've
engaged with and then
some of the other ones listed here
pretty much every continent maybe with
the exception of antarctica
and then at the bottom of the slide i
say well you know you're an old
program you're you're getting old but
but despite
our age we really focus on continually
improving the program and
and updating it so for example you uh
if you go back and look at our
curriculum from five to seven years ago
you might see
well maybe it would there be was the
beginnings of machine learning
um but you know we we keep up with what
is really important for the field
um the um so
as a graduate program we award the
common graduate degrees um so the doctor
of philosophy or phd
which is mainly for people who want to
pursue research
or academia although sometimes other
careers
we we actually have two flavors of our
master's degree and these have gone by
different names over the years so these
are the
current names of our programs um we
basically say master of science with
thesis and master of science non-thesis
and the this reflects that that
master's degrees in the world have
really kind of bifurcated into research
masters and professional masters and our
um two master's options reflect that so
research masters
sometimes they're pursued by someone who
has a doctoral degree in another field
doesn't really need to get another
doctoral degree
but they still want to do research um
kind of in it so they
sometimes people use the term postdoc
masters
or the um professional masters
and and certainly as there's been growth
in all
uh fields in professional master's
degrees
and then our graduate certificate which
we started when we started teaching our
courses online
um because we didn't actually think that
back around the
uh when we started teaching online in
1999
that people would want to get a master's
degree so we started this thing called
the graduate certificate
which other informatics programs now
offer
um but we actually found that there were
enough people who did want to get our
master's degree so we
in the early 2000s moved our entire
master's degree program online
and and it remains um so this
is a kind of a matrix of the two majors
and the different um uh degree options
um so the even though there are more
online than on campus students in our
program they are all
either in the graduate certificate or
the um
master's non-thesis people can sometimes
do a thesis
online if uh if if they wish and we we
have a way to accommodate that
um all of the the the phd program the
bcb program
are on campus however for the last
year and three or four months
everything's been virtual
and so everything has moved online
i think our hope our plan is that
the on-campus programs when ohsu fully
opens up which we're planning for
starting with the fall quarter in
september
we will resume having students on campus
although like many industries
education will probably
have a kind of mixed model of
making more use of online and virtual
uh activities um when when the pandemic
um is is over so there's a planning
process going on right now
with um at ohsu like with many
universities to
um reopen by the fall and for those of
you who
live in oregon know the state of oregon
has
as of yesterday has reopened
and hopefully things will continue to
return toward normal
um in in oregon and and other states
um a little bit about the curriculum in
all of our programs
um so each major and each degree
have the curriculum organized into
domains um
so for health and clinical informatics
the domains are like health care
computer science
organizational behavior and management
um
and and a few a couple others and each
of those domains has
required courses these other ones called
individual competency
where you choose from a menu and then
electives
and then the degree programs
are basically um built around something
we call the knowledge base which is
for each of the two majors that that
kind of core
set of courses in the different domains
make up the knowledge base and then if
you do the masters with thesis you do a
master's thesis
if you do the master's non-thesis you do
a capstone which can also be an
internship um it's a little bit less
intense and has fewer credits than the
thesis
and then if you're in the phd you do the
knowledge base
you do additional advanced work
including advanced coursework
and then ultimately your dissertation
um another way to look at our program is
a kind of stacked
uh or building block approach um
so there's the graduate certificate
again which is only for hcin
there are um and then that
that is in turn a subset of the masters
programs and then so then you have the
knowledge base and the master's programs
and then that um that
that is in turn a subset of the phd
so i've mentioned before that
informatics
career pathways have different inputs
and outputs
and oftentimes what you do as an output
will be dependent on what you came in
with
and so one
a classic example of this is is the job
of chief
medical information officer which is
typically a physician or other
healthcare professional
so you probably would not be a computer
scientist or
a librarian or some other occupation
and then go through our program and be a
cmio
um but as you can see on the left the
the different we
we have healthcare professionals who
come in um
natural and life sciences we we have a
fair number of computer science and
related fields
um health information management and a
whole smattering of other
uh backgrounds of people business
librarian information science and others
then they all get mixed in in graduate
education
they stop and get their education and
then they go out and take different jobs
and
and usually the jobs that they take are
dependent both on um their studies but
also what they
came in with um so there's no real like
single career pathway it's not like
um medicine or law where
you know i i guess people come into
medical school with different
backgrounds but you pretty much emerge
um you know with an md degree you know
and and i suppose there's some
uh diversity and the kinds of different
things that graduates of md programs do
some of them become directors of
informatics programs but
anyways the the point of this slide is
just that there's a lot of
variation both in the inputs and the
outputs from the graduate program
um another um way to
um look at um what uh
informatics um does is is by um
what is the workforce who say they work
in informatics does so our
professional association the american
medical informatics association
a few years ago undertook a workforce
analysis and they focused on two
distinct audiences the the bottom one
the clinical informatics subspecialty
though that that is a subspecialty for
physicians um and um
physicians you know again are an
important group in the
um program and the field but
by no means all but not even half
but there is a formal pathway for
physicians
to now get board certified in clinical
informatics
so there has been a fair amount of work
kind of focusing on
physicians in informatics so that's the
bottom analysis the upper analysis is
basically the larger health informatics
field
but the irony of this analysis was they
were done by two separate processes
and almost came up with identical
uh tasks so there are some papers that
have been written they're available on
the
amia website i i can if any
they're actually open access so you um
don't need to go through library to get
them
um but interestingly enough there are
five domains
that um contribute to to the work
that informatics professionals do so
there's the foundational knowledge
of knowing about
if if you work in healthcare about
healthcare if you work in public health
knowing about public health
knowing some of the foundational aspects
of the informatics field
but then then the the second domain is
the um um kind of decision making
decision support
um oftentimes in the healthcare context
that that's used to improve care
delivery and outcomes
but that's an important part about
informatics obviously there's the
information
systems and all the issues related to
or their organization their security
how their data is organized and things
like that
so either health information systems or
enterprise information systems
a fourth domain is around data
data governance data analytics data
science
and in an analysis that was done of
physicians
back in 2009 um led by reid gardner
and colleagues the the data one was not
explicitly called out
but since that time data has become so
central to um healthcare and biomedical
informatics that it has its own domain
now
and then the fifth domain is um
leadership professionalism um what
sometimes people
call the soft skills although for many
of us the soft skills are really hard
and um but they're so important as
anyone who works in a hospital knows
sometimes the technology is the easy
part you know
just getting the system running getting
the network up and running
and then but getting the system so that
it serves people so that there's
leadership
um so that the systems are are used
to their um uh best extent
is is really important so um this helps
us understand the work of informatics
professionals
some of you may ask however since one of
the
hot topics the in the last few years has
been data science
so where does data science fit in some
colleagues of mine wrote this paper
and the lead author is philip payne it
was published in the journal jamia
open and they tried to distinguish you
know what distinguishes data science
from informatics and i actually think
this
figure which maybe looks kind of busy if
you're seeing it for the first time
captures it well but if we start at the
very top at 12 o'clock
um all of the world that we deal with
um in informatics and probably
everything else
is either biological social
technological
um so health care um personal health all
that
all those things are part of that and
all of those processes especially in
this day and age
of information technology generate data
um in healthcare we generate data about
patients for individuals
we generate they they may generate data
about themselves
wearable social media um there may be
other sources of data public health data
another important source of data is
related to social determinants of health
and so from that data we wanted
glean knowledge so we can make
decisions and help individuals
either have better health care outcomes
or better health
outcomes better health pain and
colleagues
in this diagram call that the afferent
process we go from the world
to knowledge and and this is where
data science is critical although
informatics does this kind of work as
well as we like to remind people we were
doing it before there was a term called
data science
but um the world doesn't stop at
analyzing the data we want to be able
we actually need ways to use that data
to implement
in actual systems whether it's
health care systems or health care
information systems and we want those
systems to be
usable we want users of those systems to
be able to
take that knowledge and actually apply
it to the real world and that's the
efferent
cycle and so that's where
data feeds back to the biological social
and technological
processes and this is almost exclusively
the purview of informatics i mean there
there's obviously overlap here
um but thing and the core skills you see
are different so
um evaluation you know evaluating
systems um implementation science
organizational theory human computer
interaction
workflow a huge issue related to
um electronic health records for
clinicians
so these are kind of what distinguish
data science and informatics the the two
fields overlap
and are synergistic and
maybe are almost really one and the same
so um that's all i wanted to say
um about uh in our talk today i did want
to leave
some time for questions and comments
um we will uh we'll make these slides
available
um many of you know our presence on the
online we have a youtube channel where
all of these talks including this one
are posted we have a website for the
department
we have a blog for the department
that anyone is welcome to
contribute to we have a presence on
social media
we have a twitter account that we try to
use to
publicize things about the program a
linkedin group
and a facebook group so um
i also have a
presence on the web on the internet most
of you know
and if anyone has any questions they can
follow up with me
so i am going to stop sharing
at this point and i am happy
to um uh answer any questions
um i um
um see that there's a few
comments um including one from a
graduate of our program michelle bobo
who's been working on david dore's team
i actually didn't know that it's good to
hear um
and so uh interested in learning more
about the department
i i can say that um our
research you know our thursday
conferences which don't always
take place thursday sometimes we might
have them at a different time if
someone can't speak at the usual time or
at the end of an academic term where
a fair number of people are defending
theses and dissertations and so forth
um they um
we have them at different times if you
you get the notification about the
conference
in the um if you're if you're on one of
our email lists so we have an email list
for faculty we have an email list for
students
we have an email list for our fellows we
have an email list for our alumni
although lynn schwabe also keeps a
separate list of people who just want to
be notified about the conferences
um you're always welcome we we used to
stream them
in the days before the pandemics so when
we
would have them in the bic theater
which is still there um it's
very empty these days and but maybe
someday we'll go back to being there
we used to serve pizza which is always a
draw
and maybe someday we'll go back to that
but that's all all to be determined
any any other questions or or comments
from anyone
about the field
[Music]
any changes or evolutions within the
department you foresee in the next two
to four years
that's a great question um i
don't know that the department will
change i'm sure it will
i mean things new opportunities pop up
um
you know i i think that i think the good
news is that the department is pretty
well established in the school of
medicine
um actually um
i have no imminent plans to retire but
at some point um
i may maybe i when i'm kicked out
um but um you know there could be
leadership changes
there could be other uh changes um
but i i mean i i think one good thing
about the department is that we've
become pretty well established
um we people recognize the contributions
that informatics and clinical
epidemiology play
in medicine and health care
um um and um
we're we've been uh fiscally
responsible with our budgets and so
forth so we're not going to be
thrown out for that reason um and so
yeah so i i think
i i don't know of any um
um uh imminent changes but you'll hear
if we do
um and um so and i see that uh kate
voltales who
runs the uh los angeles office of
demacia
actually um probably with the pandemic
now we may have more
remote people but we're unfortunately
unable to deliver the
pizza to the los angeles office
any other um comments
if not um we we also um
don't make people hang around if if
we're
done for the hour if we finish early um
let me just make a few comments um
to the new interns um what one of you is
actually working with me
karen and the others um
i hope that we get to spend some time
together it
i suppose one of the downsides to to our
more virtual
um arrangement these days is that um
you know we won't uh be there in the
room together just
chatting um i also know that um
some of the new um
some of the attendees here are our new
clinical informatics
fellows um so again we um
there's a a relatively new training
process
for physicians and um
uh so we have a and physicians who
uh become sub-specialists usually do a
subspecialty fellowship
ohsu like many aspects of the field has
been in the lead on this we were one of
the first programs
and um
so i know that i think some of the i
think
the the new fellows um are also
attending
this session as well and i know i'll be
meeting with you all
again virtually maybe
this summer um we can find ways i
actually have a pretty open and
uh airy backyard and as the rules change
maybe we can
find some ways to to get together in
person um
i also uh note in the chat and i want to
call out chris alpy who's here
and chris is our university librarian so
she heads
the library which is actually a
tremendous resource one of the
one of the complaints we get from
graduating students
is that they lose access to the library
um
and not not so much the physical space
although they do lose that too if
they're on campus
but the extensive holdings you know
almost
you know you know all of which these
days are virtual are online
we subscribe to i don't know um how many
uh thousands of journals um that you
know unfortunately you can't always get
access to um if you're not a student so
um um anyway so uh
for all the students and interns and
everyone else the library is a
tremendous resource
and when the building opens up again um
we it's in our building so you can walk
into the building and access the library
and
and and the library is not just uh the
resources it's it's the people as well
and
and a number of the library staff
interact with our program
so thank you for bringing that up chris
um and she i see you're waving there
um uh i'm looking at
um someone asked what is my favorite
uh well i i don't actually work in
bioinformatics i'm
more kind of on the clinical health and
clinical informatics side but
i i don't know that there's a favorite
project of all time
there are really important ones that
have really transformed
not not only informatics but the
healthcare field
certainly the human genome project if
we're actually talking about
bioinformatics
the the original sequencing of the human
genome and of course now we can sequence
a genome
for a thousand dollars although it costs
a lot more money to interpret it
we um there's projects other projects
from the national library medicine
pubmed which is freely available
although again sometimes you
click to a journal article and you hit a
paywall which
ohsu if we subscribe to that journal you
can get around
uh maybe the the the high-tech
project of uh in the around 2009-2010
that really ramped up the use of
electronic health records
um what other yeah i um
obviously there's all my individual
projects which are kind of favorites for
me i don't know that they're
as impactful on the field but i um i
myself do work in search systems um
like pubmed and google but really more
on the research side of those
i can't really compete with the national
library of medicine or google
and thank you to chris for pointing out
the
projects in our archives our we do um
publish
our theses and dissertations in
the uh digital library that ohsu has
you can actually um our website
connects you to our faculty and so
there are profiles or other kinds of web
pages that they have or you can search
pubmed for them to find
[Music]
projects uh um things that faculty have
done
actually see that the interns have been
introducing themselves too i saw
palmer bassett uh earlier
um and um karen garcia who's working
with me
i see um jalen patel
who's working with dr rybar
and i see another question from
gabriella
for someone who that is uncertain about
how they want to pursue science
how might this program provide clarity
um
that's a good question um and you know
that is a
at least if i i think i'm interpreting
it right
um how um you know how does one decide
what they want to do with their career
or even how does one decide
once they've decided they want to do
informatics as a career what
area they might be focused in um you
know the key thing
is to expose yourself
to the field um
you know we um on the
on the health and clinical informatics
side we actually have our introductory
course
that i teach myself because i really
enjoy
teaching that um but you know
um learning more about the field and
what interests you
and and these days um you know i can
remember a time
you know for example when i was
finishing my medical training in the
1980s and i told
one of the faculty that i was going off
to do
um and i see virginia there i will get
to you in a second
um uh you know i i told the fact is what
are you going to do you know you're
going to go into private practice you're
going to go
do a sub-specialty fellowship like no
i'm going to go do this thing called
informatics and he's like what's that
and then he made this comment you know
so i
said well it's working with computers
and and his comment
um which was um
[Music]
weird back then and certainly weird
these days was
well you know why why do you want to use
computers uh doctors should have all the
knowledge in their head
and and that was not true in the 1980s
and it's certainly not true
at the present time there is so much
more information
than um any physician
nurse or really anyone in any field can
have
in their brain and so um really the
the better approach to um
bringing knowledge to doctors you know
which is part of what my research focus
is in
informatics is to really build them
systems that help them quickly get to
high quality information that they need
um and there's there are different ways
to do that
and some ways are better than others and
so
even though i see a lot of doctors
googling things and
many google searches do bring up very
high quality information
but now with all of our fake news and
all that other stuff
one needs to approach the internet with
um
um caution um and um
and then another way you know for those
of you who are in the program
um virginia lanky's who um
is i i see her a little cut cutout you
can wave virginia
and she is our
career development director so she um
and she
has over the years be is like our number
one source of knowledge on the job
market because she scours the job ads we
actually have an email list
for students in the program
that is just a steady stream of job
announcements um i post to that email
list as well because
uh people also send job announcements to
me
um and um and in fact seeing the jobs
that are out there is a way to
um learn more about the field because
you see what
people are hiring uh people to do um
and um you know the the best
hopefully the best outcome in life is
that you have a job that
is something you really enjoy if you're
something you like to do and no one's
willing to pay you to do it then you
obviously can't do that as a job
um but um you know if you can find a job
and
and i think many of us who do work in
the field have jobs that we
for the most part enjoy as i commonly
tell people
i like going to work almost all days
there are sometimes things with my job
that
i would prefer not to have to deal with
but i think that's true of any job but
but i think
um most people who work in informatics
are really
um really enjoy this kind of overlap
of people information and technology
related to health so
um marie
um currently in my class that's great to
hear
starting the hcin program and um
uh we uh is is pleased with our
um asynchronous delivery uh you know
again we
um we were one of the first programs to
start doing online learning the
technology was uh very different when we
started about
we started we we offered my introductory
course for the first time in 1999
um and that was a time when most people
connected to the internet by telephone
modem
and so you couldn't have a lot of
graphics and you always worry that
you're going to drop your connection
but we have learned a lot over the years
we um another
nice thing about our students is that
they're very engaged and they give us
frank and honest feedback that help us
improve the program
and and i think um you know we've we've
learned uh
to do it well um and um
you know we've we've found you know the
things that
that students find important um and and
you know again we we were doing um um
you know for example some some students
like
and still like although it seems less
you know to
interact in real time so you know we we
were using
um xe before ohsu went to webex we used
to use zoom
um or some of the other ones before that
um but
being able to have virtual conferences
so
our online students you know from
literally
all over the world then we have to deal
with challenges of time zones
but um we've
been using those as well
good um
okay well um i'm not seeing any new uh
comments i actually uh
uh appreciate those who typed into the
chat
and um i um again i welcome the new
interns and and others who are
newly starting the program uh we we do
want to interact with you
uh even before the pandemic but
certainly during the pandemic the best
way to reach us is by email
we we all spend time probably too much
time on webex but
we're always happy to have a webex
chat with you if you want to
talk to us one of the faculty or the
staff and um
i wish everyone well and um um
you know those who are starting in the
program i look forward to continuing to
interact with you
probably in the immediate term virtually
but perhaps in real time
there are some some students who um
i've actually interacted with quite a
bit but i've still actually never met
in person okay well thank you everyone
and um have a great day and have a great
um
holiday weekend and we'll see you soon
take care bye
you